all right now the 28 year old suspect in
the murders of the four Idaho college
students waived extradition today in
Pennsylvania and will be brought right
to Moscow Idaho to face charges joining
us now are the parents of victim Kaylee
Gonzalez Steve and Christy Gonzalez are
with us along with their attorney
Shannon gray
um
you know
Steve I I look at you as a father and
look at your your bride next to you
and I've thought this all throughout my
life that there's nothing worse than
losing a child
it's taken a long time
first of all does that give you any
Peace of Mind do you want to know
details where where are you in this
grieving process I would imagine that's
not something you get over
I honestly I feel a little bit lucky
knowing that we have somebody in there's
a person of interest nothing feels worse
than having nobody and just nothing but
doubt in seven weeks of that or close to
seven weeks of that was
a tremendous amount of pressure on us
and you know your children look for you
to tell them what what's going to happen
and how things are going to go and and
you can't you can't you can't control
anything and you just sit back and you
just wait and it's it's very hard to get
over
Christy you're you're a mom this is your
your precious your beautiful daughter
and you will never see her again I can't
imagine all the pain you're going
through as a mom
it's terrible just as anybody could
imagine
um it's just like a nightmare that you
just never ever wake up from I don't
there's not a second throughout the day
that I don't think about Kaylee and what
happened to her it's sickening
you know Steve it took the law
enforcement a while it looks like they
got very very they went very deep and
they were very creative and they looked
at databases and they were able to match
DNA from a database which I think was
pretty sophisticated
investigating on their part uh how do
you feel the police have handled all of
this
well there's a lot of pressure even for
them I think that you know it's never
fat fast enough for a father you're
impatient and you want to know
everything right then and there but I
feel good I feel like they've done a
tremendous job I know that they have
been working hard we just had a lot of
holidays these guys were working out of
town I really appreciate all the effort
that they gave I mean there was times
where I was tough on them but I know
these are strong men and women and I
know they can handle just a little bit
of pushback and we are where we want to
be and they put us there
Christy I know for myself I have two
kids if this ever happened to me I can't
put myself in your shoes I get you you
can't really understand unless you go
through something like that what would
you what would you like assuming there's
a guilty verdict in this case the
murderer of your daughter what do you
think that just punishment is
then went in there that night with the
intent to kill and showed no mercy
um I'm provoked and killed our daughter
her best friend and their two friends
um
uh we're glad that we live in the state
of Idaho with the death penalty
Shannon we'll give you the last word as
the lawyer from the legal side
um you know that the evidence that they
have you know more probably than the
public where do you see it going
well we're looking forward to the
probable cause affidavit and seeing what
information they have in that affidavit
it won't show the entire case obviously
but will give us an idea of what hard
evidence they have towards the defendant
in this case and we're hopeful that it's
strong and moving forward you know we're
just the beginning of the criminal
justice system so it's still a long haul
from here but we're hopeful and
optimistic
all right Shannon thank you Steve and
and Christy I'm so sorry and I know I
speak for my entire entire audience when
I say that you're in our prayers
um this is a heartbreaking story and I
hope he gets the Justice he deserves
thank you both hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else